ten years ago supercell was just about
to release clash of clans they didn't
know it at the time but clash of clans
would become one of the most popular
mobile games of all time they would
follow up clash of clans with boom beach
clash royale and brawl stars and before
you knew it supercell became one of the
most recognizable game developers in the
world and it wasn't long until they
started hosting tournaments and handing
out massive prizes despite this roaring
success over the past few years
supercell has lost much of the momentum
that they once had most of their games
have lost the vast majority of their
interest and we're not talking about
declines of 40 to 50 percent we're
talking about declines of over 80
percent clash of clans for example only
pulls in five percent of the interest
that it once used to similarly boom
beach only poison four percent of the
interest that it once used to a similar
story can be seen with clash royale as
well
the only major supercell game that
hasn't suffered to decline is brawl
stars but even brawl stars is
experiencing quite a significant decline
on top of this many of the new games
from supercell like rush wars and heyday
pop were outright shut down due to
concerns regarding longevity and as for
the new games that haven't been shut
down well it's not much better for them
either take supercell's latest game at
everdale for example the interest in
everdel is so low that you can't even
see its graph relative to clash of clans
it's not just google trends that joined
this trend either socialblade paints a
very similar picture most of our
favorite clash youtubers are only
getting a fraction of the views and
subscribers that they once got in the
past three years chiefpat's subscriber
count has only increased from 2.51
million to 2.57 million his viewership
isn't that much better either he's only
getting a few hundred thousand views per
month back in his heyday he would get
more views on each video a similar story
can be seen with mold galadon nick a
knight clash with ash and so many more
now i'm 100 sure that there's gonna be
comments down below that claim that
supercell's games aren't dead and that
they still have large user bases
but honestly most of these players are
super fans or they do it as a job
virtually all of supercell's casual base
has stitched their games and looking at
the charts there's no question that
supercell is not nearly as popular as
they once used to be
so what happened to supercell
one of the primary factors that made
supercell games so popular in the first
place was their unique mode of
monetization supercell didn't charge
users directly to play the game in fact
you didn't even have to pay them a
single dime if you didn't want to rather
superso made all of their money from
people who wanted to advance faster if
you didn't want to spend years maxing
out your clash of clans base or
collecting a bunch of clash royale cards
you could spend money to speed up these
processes this unique revenue stream
allowed supercell to create quite
ambitious games up until the release of
clash of clans virtually all mobile
games were extremely simple and
rudimentary we had games like temporon
fruit ninja and the angry birds given
the limited revenue from these games
developers weren't able to spend that
much on development but with the clash
of clans individual users were spending
hundreds if not thousands of dollars on
the game which allowed supercell to
splurge on development this gave casual
players an experience that they couldn't
find anywhere else no free game mobile
or otherwise stacked up to the quality
and experience of clash of clans aside
from being extremely accessible to
casual players casual players felt that
they could do well in the game without
spending money sure they might not
become a top player in the world but it
was realistic for them to max out their
bases within a few years with the time
however we saw updates that made this
more and more difficult a perfect
example of this is wall upgrades to max
out walls you have to spend 4 million
gold per wall
only people who have played clash of
clans know how big of a pain this was
for the rest of you i'll put it in
dollar terms to max out your class of
plans base it costs 11 000
and out of this nearly 5 000 would go
towards simply maxing out walls
in other words nearly half the game was
simply maxing out walls i don't think i
need to explain why this made the game
extremely tedious and frustrating
especially for late stage players and
honestly the only reason supercell made
it so hard to max out walls is because
they knew that the top players were
willing to spend whatever it took to max
out their bases so this was an easy 5
000 from each top player while this was
extremely profitable for supercell it
didn't take long for players to feel the
supercell's game for becoming pay to win
and this became even more evident with
clash royale not only did you have to
spend insane amounts of money but you
also had to gamble a bit you see it when
clash royale was launched you couldn't
just max out each of your cards one by
one instead you had to buy chests that
gave you a random set of cards so if you
wanted to max out your account you had
to keep bank chests until random cards
happen to be exactly what you need and
on average this ended up costing nearly
thirty thousand dollars considering this
i don't think you'd be surprised here
that the vast majority of players never
play these games to the end
aside from it becoming virtually
impossible for casual players to max out
their accounts we also saw several
distractions appear for these players
while supercell was one of the first
gaming companies to leverage this
premium business model they were by no
means the last given the insane
popularity of supercell basically every
game developer became aware of this
alternative mode of monetization and it
didn't take long for them to launch
their own offerings some of the biggest
competitors include pokemon goa pubg
mobile and of course fortnite not only
did these games also offer high quality
experience for these free players but
they were arguably more fair take
fortnite for example while you could
spend tens of thousands of dollars
collecting every skin in the game this
would give you absolutely no advantage
when it came to playing the game itself
a pro player could start a new account
and their chance of winning would still
be identical as these newer games
started to gain popularity it was only
natural that people started leaving
older games it wasn't just newer games
that were siphoning supercell's user
base either another major corporate was
social media when clash of clans came
out mobile social media was in its
infancy we were just starting to see
apps like instagram and snapchat come
out so the vast majority of smartphone
users weren't using their smartphones
for social media they primarily used it
for productivity or gaming but over time
social media has risen to become the
number one use for smartphones many of
the larger social media platforms like
instagram and whatsapp oppose user
accounts in the billions
and as people started flocking over to
these social media apps it just became
even harder for supercell to hold on to
their users to make things even worse
supercell wasn't just fighting as mobile
apps either over the past five years
we've seen quite a surge in pc gaming
mostly thanks to amd
you see it in 2017 amd launched a new
series of cpus called ryzen and since
its release ryzen has substantially
reduced the cost of pc gaming this has
prompted more people than ever to switch
over to pc gaming and this trend has
simply been accentuated by the pandemic
which forced people to stay at home so
in the end many of the casual gamers
switched over to social media many of
the amateurs and enthusiasts switched
over to pc gaming and as for the
remaining mobile gamers well now they
have more quality options than ever
so far we've primarily discussed factors
that have led to gamers teaching
supercell but there's also an argument
to be made that supercell has ditched
gamers 10 years ago supercell was a
small gaming startup that was trying to
hit it big they were hungry to launch
the next big game and make their mark in
the industry but now that they've
already done that what's the motivation
to achieve something even bigger also be
sure to note that supercell's leadership
brilliantly sold the company at the peak
of their popularity in june of 2016
tension agreed to buy 84 percent of the
company at an 8.6 billion evaluation
while this was a great financial move
for the company's leadership and og
employees this was likely not a very
good move for the company's spirit you
see it super solo only had a total of
340 employees which means the buyout was
worth 25 million dollars per employee
this means that unless you joined months
before the acquisition you likely
received at least a six-figure payout
meanwhile employees that have been
around since the beginning likely
received seven figure payouts if not
multi-seven-figure payouts in other
words the vast majority of supercell
employees became well off if not
completely financially free while this
is an awesome outcome for any startup it
also drains the company of much of its
motivation a perfect example of this is
dell 10 to 15 years ago dell was facing
a relentless decline and michael delhi
even came out of retirement to save the
company and one of the biggest issues
that he found was that many of del's
employees simply didn't care they didn't
care about the future of the company nor
did they care about being fired you see
it dell stock had minted 2 700 million
years many of which were deca
millionaires in fact this was so common
that people called them billionaires the
combat is michael had to take down
private lay off significant portions of
their workforce and pivot to the server
market i don't know about you but i
don't think supercell is likely to go
through such an evolution to make things
worse i don't think their parent company
tension cares all that much either while
8.6 billion dollars is an insane amount
of money for us peasants it simply
calculated risk for tension tension has
a market cap of over 400 billion dollars
and that's after crashing over 50
percent so i don't think they're super
motivated to turn around supercell
either from their perspective they have
stakes and dozens of gaming companies
and they just need a few of them to do
really well to make up for such losses
so it's really up to supercell alone to
save themselves
in the end supercell is one of the most
iconic and nostalgic game developers in
the world
most of us have at least tried one of
their games if not played them for years
but in recent history supercell hasn't
been doing all that great their trend
towards paid win hash underway a lot of
players not to mention all the extra
competition they've been facing from
other game developers and social media
these issues have likely only been
worsened by the buyout which probably
softened morale and spirit amongst
employees and executives now it's not
like supercell is struggling to make
money they've introduced several sources
of recurring revenue throughout their
games so the remaining players are
likely quite profitable but in terms of
returning to their former glory it's
really just a coin flip supercell's best
bet is to just continue launching games
and hopefully one of them will pick up
steam but if not they'll probably just
end up supporting their most popular
games until they eventually become
unprofitable themselves at which point
they'll shut these down as well but
fortunately these games likely still
have several years left before they
become unprofitable so supercell has
quite a bit of time to figure something
out but only time will tell which
supercell game is your favorite comment
that down below also drop a like if
supercell games are nostalgic for you
and of course consider checking out our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you